[Musique]
on a aujourd'hui on en parle beaucoup en
ce moment le problème des femmes
comment expliquer qu'à notre époque
encore le salaire des femmes soit
inférieur à celui des hommes
vous évoquez à juste titre un principe
républicain auquel je suis très attaché
l'égalité des droits
l'égalité des chances ce principe ne
s'applique pas aux femmes
c'est étonnant mais c'est s et je dirais
dans la complicité général alors il ya
d'abord l'égalité des droits
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui à
travail égal
et contrairement à ce que exige la loi
la femme gagne en gros 30 % de moins que
là ce n'est pas admissible
deuxièmement il ya l'égalité des chances
lorsqu'on regarde les postes de
direction dans l'ensemble des
entreprises privées ou publiques
on s'aperçoit que le pourcentage de
femmes est très faible par rapport aux
hommes sauf dans quelques carrières
particulière donc l'égalité des chances
n'est pas non plus reconnu
comment faire je vois que nous avons
aujourd'hui des syndicats ouvriers
patronat nouveau qui aborde les choses
me semble-t-il avec beaucoup plus de
dynamisme et de réalisme que ce ne fut
le cas dans le passé et je propose que
parmi les grands sujets de société il
doit y avoir le rôle la place les droits
des femmes à l'égalité des droits à
l'égalité des chances c'est un des
objets d'une grande concertation entre
les partenaires sociaux puis
deuxièmement il n'ya pour l'un politique
les femmes en droit de vote depuis 50
ans et nous sommes aujourd'hui le pays
européens de tous où le nombre de femmes
élues et le plus faire l'ordre de 5 à 6%
pour ce qui concerne le parlement ce
n'est pas acceptable alors prenez votre
liberté et fait en sorte que la parité
soit
sinon une réalité total au moins qu'on
en soit aussi proche que possible dans
les listes de municipal ça créera déjà
un choc et ce sera un premier pas
important et poneys
[Musique]
la famille pilier fondamental la
structure notre société qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour que la famille soit mieux
équilibrée plus épanouie et puis se fait
en sorte que chacun trouve sa place
dignement doit il faut bien comprendre
qu'une collectivité le corps social
c'est comme un corps humain docteur ces
composés de cellules et quand les
cellules dépérissent c'est le corps tout
entier qui dès lors la famille est le
premier rempart la première sécurité
sociale à l'égard de sel ou de ceux qui
sont touchés ou atteints par la vie et
qui pourraient devenir des exclus il est
donc essentiel d'avoir une relance forte
de la politique régulière
[Musique]
croyez pas qu'il est aussi un problème
d'école l'impression que l'école est
plus fait pour les parents pour les
enseignants que pour les enfants
oui moi je crois que la réforme des
rythmes scolaires est une nécessité
elle est nécessaire pour je dirais les
plus fragiles de nos enfants ceux qui
sont issus des milieux les plus modestes
et qui n'ont pas l'environnement qui
compense les inconvénients que vous
venez de souligner et qui n'ont pas
normalement et facilement accès à la
culture ou d'ailleurs au sport est donc
l'objectif doit être d'abord à l'école
puis au collège puis au lycée de faire
en sorte que les disciplines de la
connaissance traditionnelle soit donné
le matin et que l'après midi soit
consacrée à la fois aux disciplines du
corps sportives et à celle de la culture
soit ce que chacun est aussi accès à la
culture
[Musique]